fear the kids have this completely  figured out already  that's the wrong take teachers there's  just like any other thing that has  institutionally been around for a long  time don't fear Innovation figure out  how to take advantage of it just think  about all the things that kids don't  have to memorize in their head anymore  because of Technology we've been had  search engines  we've had them and now with chat GDP  which has Google in Red Alert land right  now because of how  amazing this technology is  of course every kid in high school in  junior high is going to use this to  write a paper in three minutes every one  of us who are 45 and older 35 and older  25 and older wish we had this [ __ ] don't  fear it re-figure out what you want to  teach create real life scenarios have  them think do different [ __ ]  have them do different [ __ ] it's not  1987 anymore